bonsoir fabienne accrocheur merci d'être
avec nous alors c'est une voix qu'on
l'entend assez peu il faut bien lire ces
derniers temps cette tendance qui dit
mettez les enfants à l'école bien au
contraire elle est si vous êtes bien
placé puisque vous êtes pédiatre pour
parler de ça pour quoi justement avoir
voulu encourager écrire cette tribune
bonsoir l heure l'ensemble des sociétés
de pédiatrie milite depuis quelques
semaines pour le retour des enfants à
l'école
tout simplement parce que nous savons
maintenant que les enfants ne sont pas
les victimes de cette épidémie
le coc vide 19 épargne les enfants les
enfants ne sont pas contagieux et ils
peuvent retourner à l'école et les
mesures de distanciation imposé dans le
protocole pour le retour à l'école des
enfants est excessif les mesures
préconisées ne sont pas nécessaires
les enfants n'étant pas particulièrement
aaron danger la principale mesure
barrière à appliquer et à faire
comprendre aux enfants et il est facile
de leur faire comprendre cette mesure
barrière
c'est une hygiène rigoureuse des mains
les enfants doivent savoir qu'il faut
qu'il se lave les mains très souvent le
port du masque n'est pas nécessaire chez
les enfants ils ne sont pas contagieux
entre eux ils ne sont pas contagieux
pour les adultes
naturellement les adultes porteront le
masque à l'école pour se protéger entre
eux et pour protéger les enfants et par
ailleurs les enfants doivent pouvoir
retrouver une école à visage humain dans
laquelle ils peuvent s'épanouir et les
mesures qui sont prises avec des enfants
que l'on voit isolé auteurs auto à
l'intérieur d'un cercle en cours de
récréation ne nous semble pas compatible
avec un retour à l'école en toute
sécurité pour les enfants les enfants
doivent pouvoir s'épanouir à l'école ils
ont besoin de boue
ils ont besoin de retrouver leur école
d'avant vous êtes en train de dire c'est
important parce qu'il ya eu tellement de
choses dit pour tout et son contraire
que finalement la plupart des enfants
qui sont infectés par le cos vide le
sont plus tôt par les adultes et pas l
inverse c'est quelque chose que vous
êtes en mesure de nous affirmer avec
certitude aujourd'hui déjà il y a très
peu d'enfants qui ont été malades du
coït 19 et les enfants qui ont été
malades ne se sont pas contaminées dans
les écoles les enfants malades se sont
tous contaminés au contact d'adultes et
dans à l'intérieur leur cellule
familiale puisque c'est au sein de la
cellule familiale qu'il y ait plus
d'interactions il n'y a pas eu
d'épidémie de quoi vite 19 dans les
écoles d'ailleurs il ya des pays dans
lesquels les écoles n'ont pas été fermé
et il n'y a pas eu plus de sniffer une
plus de problèmes qu en france en france
il a fallu fermer les écoles parce qu'il
a fallu confiné parce que l'épidémie est
partie très vite et les hôpitaux étaient
débordés et donc il a fallu tout fermé
laisser les enfants à la maison
mais maintenant qu'on sort de ce pic
épidémique
c'est les enfants peuvent retourner à
l'école comme cela se passe dans nos
pays dans d'autres pays en europe en
allemagne en suisse en hollande les
enfants retournent à l'école avec des
mesures d'hygiène simples
il ya quand même certains pays justement
j'allais venir nos voisins européens
comme par exemple et les italiens et qui
ont préféré attendre septembre pour
remettre les enfants à l'école
pour quelle raison dans ce cas ci ce
n'est pas dangereux ils ont des fausses
informations
les mesures prises sont prises par les
gouvernements et chacun prend les
mesures qu'ils jugent nécessaires
l'italie a été particulièrement touché
et il faut parfois aussi du temps pour
se remettre
mais en france nous pouvons reprendre
l'école sens
sans danger pour les enfants nous sommes
totalement rassurant pour les enfants
alors on voit que la majorité des
parents environ 60 % sont encore très
inquiet et ne compte pas mettre leurs
enfants à l'école
alors c'est vrai que quand on écoute
voilà les médias on lit la presse on
regarde la télévision on entend beaucoup
de choses qui paraissent inquiétante
beaucoup d'experts qui déconseille
d'envoyer les enfants à l'école s'est
rajouté à cela le fameux syndrome de
kawasaki dont on a parlé
est ce que pour vous il ya une une voix
un petit peu majoritaire qui contribue à
inquiéter les parents en france
nous les pédiatres
nous n'avons pas été nous n'avons pas
inquiéter les parents au début de
l'épidémie nous ne connaissions pas le
coronavirus nous pensions qu'ils se
comportaient un peu comme le virus de la
grippe mais nous avions déjà vu que les
enfants étaient peu malade
la seule inquiétude que nous avions
c'était que les enfants soient comme
pour la grippe des réservoirs à virus et
qu'ils allaient ramener le virus à la
maison nous savons depuis que cela n'est
pas vrai les enfants sont porteurs du
coc vide 19 et ne sont pas les
réservoirs à gru ce que l'on pensait
alors les familles ont été beaucoup
inquiété parce que nous avons vécu une
épidémie inédite il y a eu énormément
d'informations mais nous les pédiatres
avons toujours été particulièrement
rassurant concernant les enfants même au
pic de l'épidémie les services de
pédiatrie était vide il n'y avait pas
d'enfants dans les services d'urgence et
nous dans nos cabinets après le début du
confinement les enfants n'étant plus en
collectivité nous ne voyons plus
d'urgence dans nos cabinets
donc nous n'avons jamais alerté les
parents par rapport aux coronavirus et
le coronavirus n'est pas une pathologie
pédiatrique justement ma question c'est
est pourquoi votre voix était aussi peu
audible ces dernières semaines puisque
vous me confirmez vous n'avez jamais été
inquiet mais c'est vrai que votre voix
celle des pédiatres été assez peu
entendu la preuve 60 % des parents
restés
allemands inquiets alors il est sûr que
comme cette pathologie touche et
massivement la population adulte
on a beaucoup sur les chaînes sur les
médias ont énormément parler d'eux des
hôpitaux sous tension et la pédiatrie
n'a pas été en première en premier lieu
en donc nous nous avons toujours été
rassurant mais probablement peu entendu
nous avons dès le début de l'épidémie
communiqué sur la nécessité de
poursuivre les vaccination des
nourrissons et ça s'est extrait très
important parce que nous savions que
nous allons nous inscrire sur la durée
et qu'il fallait continuer à vacciner
les nourrissons pour ne pas les exposer
à d'autres pathologies beaucoup plus
grave
le corona virus n'est pas dangereux chez
les enfants par contre si on ne vaccine
pas on risque d'avoir des méningites au
risque d'avoir des coqueluches donc nous
avons dès le début
communiqué sur la nécessité de suivre
les enfants nous avons organisé nos
cabinets pour pouvoir recevoir les
nouveaux nés les petits nourrisson que
nous avons continué à vacciner et après
très rapidement nous avons aussi
communiquer sur la nécessité de sortir
les enfants de l'isolément de pouvoir
éventuellement les sortir un petit peu
mais en période de confinement c'était
compliqué et depuis que l'on parle de
retour de l'école nous sommes tout à
fait confiants sur le retour à l'école
ma toute dernière question j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure le fameux syndrome de
kawasaki la presse s'en est fait est qu
il ya quelques semaines au moment
d'ailleurs on parlait de de rouvrir les
écoles aujourd'hui c'est un danger que
vous écarter ce qu'on lançait un petit
peu plus déjà ce qu'il est lié aux
coronavirus la maladie de kawasaki est
une maladie que nous pédiatre
connaissons c'est une maladie qui
survient régulièrement
après des infections diverses et variées
c'est une tout simplement à des règles
un dérèglement du système immunitaire de
l'enfant qui fait suite à une agression
infectieuses qui parfois peut être tout
à fait passer inaperçu l' alerte est
liée au fait que habituellement les
services hospitaliers voit à peu près un
cas par mois de maladie de kawasaki et
là d'un coup il y a eu un nombre de cas
est levée une quinzaine puis un peu plus
une trentaine une cinquantaine à
l'hôpital necker notamment il y en a eu
dans d'autres hôpitaux
alors effectivement il y a un lien avec
le coronavirus puisque ces enfants ont
eu une sérologie positive mais c'est
quelque chose qui reste rare
il n'y a pas eu de cas graves c'est
quelque chose qui se soigne il y à un
traitement sont des injections
d'immunoglobuline donc tous ces enfants
sont guéris il y a probablement un lien
mais ce n'est pas grave
et c'est extrêmement rare donc ça ne
change pas notre discours rassurant par
rapport aux familles effectivement ça a
été énormément médiatisé mais c'est
quelque chose qui rares doivent nous
restons très rassurant
merci beaucoup fabienne colère d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt front